all right Alicia is with us in
Greenville South Carolina right Alicia
how are you - doing well yourself
better than I deserve what's up I'm here
with my husband Patrick and we're having
the discussion on whether to rent or buy
Patrick's main argument is my student
loans I just graduate from pharmacy
school last year I have two hundred and
forty five thousand dollars good lord
mm-hmm performance at school yes I went
to undergrad I got four-year degree so
you have paid for nothing yet huh sorry
so you haven't paid for anything yet um
yes we paid them we got much cut out
good Lord so what have you gotten a job
I do good how are get CBS thank God so
what do you make in 110 yes that one's
in and I'm also working in an outpatient
clinics your make you are making 110 yes
well I was bringing I guess with both of
ours is probably about 165 plus the up
as I include the outpatient yeah 165
okay and you've been used to living on
his income right okay so that means if
we put all of your income towards the
student loans you would be out of debt
in two and a half years correct and
that's what you need to do right
you need to clear up your student loans
let me just tell you talisha I'm
listening to your tone of voice and the
way you're carrying this you act like
this is not a big deal you need to act
like your freakin life is about to come
to an end this is a disaster and if you
act like this is okay and are nonchalant
about it you're going to have this debt
for 25 years I'm not not talking about I
know that they do okay just the way
you're the way it sounded in your tone
on the air that's a way it came off so
maybe I misread you I apologize then but
yeah you know you if I'm you I'm in
panic mode and yeah I would have to
agree with your husband I think is the
way you said that maybe it was you I'm
agreeing with it I remember who it was
but now we're not buying nothing and
we're not going on vacation and we're
not we're not gonna I mean we're not
going out to eat we're going to stay
home and we're going to clean up this
unbelievably large mess
as fast as we possibly can because
here's the ratio I know you're bright
because you don't get through pharmacy
school if you're dumb so here's the
formula for getting out of debt the more
passionate you are whether it's an anger
passion of fear passion whatever it is
the more passionate you are about
becoming a debt free the deeper you
sacrifice and the deeper you sacrifice
mathematically the faster you get out
does that make sense yeah and so I would
much prefer that you do this very very
quickly so then two and a half years
from now I'm saying they're looking at a
couple by then you're probably making
200 between the two of you and you're
still very young and man you'll be able
to do anything you want to the rest of
your life
couple hundred thousand bucks and no
debt yeah but if you if you play around
with this snake it's just going to keep
biting you and keep biting you you're
never going to turn the corner you're
never going to break free of it and that
just it's just an amazing amount of debt
and I would just go bananas to get rid
of it as fast as possible on the problem
is you've been in the pharmacy world of
the same thing is true in the medical
world of the law world that the debt is
some normalized that everybody acts like
it's just it's always going to be there
and oh well whatever and I wouldn't act
that way I would go bananas and get rid
of it as fast as possible and no I would
not buy a house I would rent the
cheapest thing a little garage apartment
out back at somebody's house and you
know where the where the utilities are
furnished and you can mow the old lady's
grass for free rent or something I mean
just go bananas where your broke friends
are all making fun of you for two years
and in two years two and a half years
you'll be done you could even do it
faster than two and a half but because
you're not used to this income yet you
haven't started making it just barely so
please do that please do that that's my
game
you